Hey guys, how's it going? It's Justine and today we're going to be taking a look at the new Macbook Pro.
This is the 15 inch with the touch bar.
I did a live unboxing which was the first time I've ever unboxed anything live, I'll put a link in the description if you guys want to watch that
And also an annotation or a card somewhere on the screen.
So here it is. Now the first thing that a lot of people have been talking about is.......
The....Apple logo. So in a lot of ways they went for the same look as the Macbook Air, the Air had the very metallic,
Apple logo, they basically completely redesigned the keyboard.
But this is a... this is it guys, we've got our Thunderbolt 3 but also USB C compatible ports.
2 on this side we also have 2 on this side
and we also have our headphone jack.
Something that I thought was funny is they removed the headphone Jack on the iphone, which is fine,
but they put one in the new Macbook pros, but they also didn't give you a way to charge your new
iPhone 7.
This is lightning. These are USB-C. You'll have to get another
cable to be able to charge your iphone with your new MacBook Pro . So my solution for this -
I bought this. I told you guys to buy [this] and I'm sure many of you actually did get it if you're planning on buying
this MacBook Pro, or if you have a MacBook air?
So this is a five and one USB- C Hub and this is in the slate gray colour.
It's not exactly the same color as this [Macbook], so it's gonna
kind of drive me a little [bit] nuts and also something that's started driving me
super crazy is this little light is blue, and the caps locks key is green. [so] when they're both on..
trigger warning.
but for the time being this is what we're going [to] be using as you can see it is two usb 3.0
ports it also has an sd
Card slot and Micro Sd. Card slot and also one usb C slot let's open up our little Macbook and
as I was talking about the blue and the green
[can] also tell the color difference not sure if you can see that well on camera
The thing that you will notice is how massive this
TouchPad is I was actually in shock when I first saw because it's it's huge
[here's] my hand the touchpad is bigger than the iPhone 7 I wish the apple pencil would work on this that would have been
So awesome don't want to try it. I'm gonna see just just a double check and make sure it doesn't work I
Tell you what you can't do
Stick this in there. I'll charge my pencil while we wait now
I'd like to take you guys through a little bit of the touch bar features and
Also, see what it looks like in final cut and just take it for a [quick] spin so as you can see here
This is our lovely little unlock screen
And if learning me that I can unlock with touch id which I already set up, so let's do it touch
Unlocked [of] course the highlight of this macbook is the touch bar which you'll see here
You guys aren't asking me what the touch bar feels like it feels, sort of like the trackpad
But a little bit slicker kind of feels like your iphone, but a little less shiny so as you can see here
This is final cuts the touch bar
Changes depending upon what app you have open so this is back to the finder so the finder opens up with
Corresponding one assist, but I haven't even tried all these things out
There's a lot of things to get used to click to final cuts
This will allow me to import footage just by touching the touch bar
Let's see if I can find myself some footage. I think I set myself a couple files. It's fast. This is all 4k footage
Send that in
Kind [of] fast so this looks like it's just a trim I
Just trimmed this entire clip using the touch bar
Let's see it will turn this volume down and this is the volume that's actually adjusting the track on the clip [fears] see that
Hey, Siri, open up pages
here's a blank document as
You can see change is corresponding to whatever it
is that you're doing this basically looks kind of like your iphone when you're typing it brings up the suggestion bar right here is the
Emojis which is something that I am pretty [excited] about
Because I love emojis so right here. You can see this is the entire timeline
In final cut [so] I'm just scrolling my finger back and forth and I can see everything. Oh this is going to be so
Exciting guys, I'm going to edit this video on final cut on the new Mac, Pro
And I'll let you know how it goes in [a] future video
so now something that I like to do and I love doing this when I get new products is do a comparison of then and
Now so this is where we currently are now I?
Would like to show you guys my first Macbook ever
This is the Macbook that
started it all
I made my first
[YouTube] videos on this any of the first ask I dFs's I actually shot those with the isight camera and a little blue microphone
This is in part. What was it called eyesight then it's called facetime camera, so there's some yeah, it was called on sight then oh
These are really heavy and here. She is the [baby] that started it all
[oh] look at them next to each other. [oh], honey
I mean this thing still had a cD slot. [I] didn't even have a charger that would work with this anymore
Definitely lost and this has the removable battery
Well doesn't look like it's charged. Oh
Wow, oh boy look how little oh boy you're so teeny
Something that used to drive me crazy. Is that the space bar was not lined up with the trackpad?
We've come so far
There's a few missing in between because I usually will do a pass down computers if I get a new one
I will give it to a family member, or I just like to keep them because some people collect photographs
Some people like to remember memories. I remember [my] life through which Macbook or apple product I had
so yeah
So this is the current one that I'm using this is my baby
We've been through a lot
Now we're going to check out. This is the first Macbook air
This is a great computer. It was so slow it also took a small little
[Little] fall, you can see there
But it still worked [and] now something that is the closest companion to this is
The latest Macbook air which really is an incredible device. I was still able to edit 4k footage on this granted. It's
Very slow, but you could still do it
Same sort of keyboard, and this is a really beautiful machine. It's really really really nice if you guys aren't doing anything
That's that insane like editing or anything [that's] [to] [processor] intensive honestly
Macbook Airs just it's really great. It's really great
[I] know we get upset at apple for not doing the things that we think they should do but man
I'll tell you what it's really beautiful. Call me a sheep. Call me foOl. I've got PCs
I know that there are computers with higher specs and in comparison to what you're paying for a mac
But a lot of what you're paying for a mac is the os and for it to work and the other
applications that work with it
You're really paying for an experience and usually for the most part that experience is so good that it is worth it
And if you're a PC person that's really fine, I get it. I still do my live streams [on] my PC
I play games on my PC, and I do edit almost everything in final cut [pro] x so for me
This is going to be the most perfect machine
It will be interesting [to] see how the editing process goes on here, though
And if it is faster if the touch bar really does help that much I think right now
It's sort of is a novelty item until you kind of figure out all of how it works, so once you do that
Then you're going to be set last but not least
Yeah, you know you can't you can't write on [it]. Oh guys that doesn't for my Macbook pro overview
I'm pretty excited to try this out
I'll probably be doing a two days with Macbook
probably a video of
Traveling with my back book for the first time and probably a week with my back book and then I mean I might as well
Do a things that I like about my Macbook video
And then I'll probably do with things that I don't like about my macbook video, and then I do problem at it
I should probably just do with things that I wish my macbook had and then maybe I'll do update with my macbook and then maybe
I'll do sleeping with my [macbook] and maybe I'll even do I don't know coffee with ice. I think it's okay
I'll see you guys later
Should I start?
Like buying like a sheep sheep called me an app [should] call me what you want what you really really want
But I like my back. Oh my sweet sweet Macbook
I just wanted to give you guys an update because I edited my entire video the video that you just watched on this little guy
sitting right here on
[this] couch I've got a this harddrive hooked up to it
It's usB see holy moly this touch bars. It's incredible. You know we made fun of [it]
[we] swept everybody makes their little jokes, but wow it is
So good [for] the smallest things you guys think shortcut keys are amazing
well
Let me tell you what touch bar shortcut keys are even shorter [a] small side note as well today when I was putting my macbook
into my backpack the Macbook
fell backwards
So I basically like put the macbook into my book bag with my face and hit off of my nose
And it was the most painful thing ever I've got like this huge bumps
Oh my goodness either way this thing's amazing. I'm so happy. I'm so
So happy I love you guys see you later
I'm so nervous
It's the space gray [oh]
You guys want to see it
Here it is. It's in its little case. It's little box. It's little